bonsoir à tous nous sommes très heureux
de vous retrouver toujours en direct de
la bibliothèque nationale pour cette
finale des championnat d'orthographe de
langue française ces championnats
mondiaux savez que nous sommes donc en
direct de la bibliothèque nationale et
c'est un grand moment évidemment dans un
instant nous allons connaître les
vainqueurs de cette finale puisque dans
un moment nous vous donnerons le corrigé
de la dictée alors j'espère que vous
étiez avec nous dès 13h20 j'espère que
vous avez fait cette dictée et
évidemment elle vous a semblé facile en
tout cas dans son début évidemment vous
vous trompez car vous vous en doutez
bernard pivot s'est fait un malin
plaisir de glisser de nombreux pièges
ses chausse trappes et vous vous en
rendrez compte assez rapidement
le jury a travaillé tout l'après midi il
lui fallait corriger 252 copie puisque
nous avons cette année deux cent
cinquante deux finalistes auxquels il
faut ajouter les dictées de sacha distel
ana prochnow jacqueline danault et celle
des journalistes de presse écrite et de
presse audiovisuelle ils étaient très
nombreux
vous savez que le phénomène important
c'est l'internationalisation cette année
nos participants viennent de 45 pays
différents
c'est dire d'une certaine manière qui
s'ils se retrouvent le monde entier dans
cette salle de travail du département
des imprimés de la bibliothèque
nationale et le moment le plus émouvant
c'était peut-être hier soir lorsque tous
nos participants étrangers se sont
rencontrés pour la première fois c'était
à l'hôtel hilton
ils ont fait connaissance sous l'oeil
attentif de thierry est regardée moi
j'aime la mère de mes villes mois de
madagascar
comme nationales étaient les chinois moi
je suis malien
on vient dire lors tous sont finalistes
du championnat du monde d'orthographe
aucune crainte qu'ils ne s'expriment
dans la langue de jack l'éventreur ils
sont bien trop amoureux de celle de
proust ou de perec
mais attention ils ne sont pas seulement
venues pour accorder les participants
mais aussi pour se découvrir nouvel ami
j'ai posé une question à une fille mais
c'est personnel et à marcher pas trop
donc c'est l'occasion de rencontres
oui ah oui et le mexique
est ce que vous êtes un petit peu
surpris de voir des gens d'autant de
pays différents
surpris désagréablement surpris et très
content de rencontrer tant de gens
venant de silwan cours d une rencontre
exceptionnelle comme sexy va prendre le
corps les nippons a disparu et vous
allez chercher le nippon
on est bien on finirait bien par leur
beauté de l'art et leur sympathie ni et
à des gens venus de tous les continents
qui sont là pour défendre les couleurs
et la francophonie et pourquoi serait
tout bénéfice
ils ont échangé leur adresse leur
téléphone et petit à petit l'émotion est
montée de pologne du togo au togo ont
par le français
partout dans la rue ses membres
officiels et un peu partout ne devrait
pas surpris de rencontrer de jeunes
togolais exprimé à la maman français non
les polonais nous sommes un peu fermé à
cause des formalités qu'il faut faire
pour sortir le payer donc rencontrer des
gens d'autres nationalités
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
c'est pour nous une chance unique et
puis la terrible dit et a ressurgi
subitement dans les conversations chacun
s'exprimant sur sa méthode de
préparation et ses craintes
les deux mots difficiles avec la matière
efficace dans la mesure où personne ne
peut empêcher tout le dictionnaire la
grammaire et l'orthographe française
parlée très difficile et pleine
exception justifiée mais difficile un
mot et je n'arrive jamais à écuires là
n'existe à oui j'ai le trac parce que
vous avez le trac un petit peu si parce
que vu la foule qu'il y avait vu
l'aspect de monsieur puis votée il a
l'air de vrais criminels a qu'une jeune
femme traite un jour de criminels
c'était mon rêve le plus secret et
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment comblé
vraiment merci merci mademoiselle de
m'avoir traité de criminel
d'ailleurs sur le 36 15 coda poste tout
là tout l'après midi on a aussi traité
un peu de syndiqués de criminels mais
très gentiment alors le on a procédé à
ce sondage sur le minitel vous avez été
d'ailleurs si nombreux que beaucoup
n'ont pas pu avoir accès directement aux
36 15 que la poste mais enfin on a
demandé à tous les gens combien de
fautes pensez vous avoir fait et 64 %
ont répondu qu'ils avaient fait
probablement plus de 10 fautes et
seulement donc 36% moins de 10 de 2 10
de 10 fautes qu'elle était le mot le
plus difficile les gens ont répondu
palimpseste 21%
cancoillotte 10% et si barry de 10% et
puis on a leur a demandé pensez vous qu
une dictée doivent comporter des pièges
de sens
en plus des pièges de grammaire et des
pièges de
de vocabulaire et bien la réponse a été
oui oui à 83% et puis pensez vous qu'il
y ait un abus des mots rares et là la
réponse c'est non à 57 % et oui donc à
43% et je vous signale que vous aurez le
corrigé de l'habiter sur le minitel 36
15 codes à poste après bien entendu que
nous aurons procédé à ce même corrigé
ici même voilà et je voudrais simplement
revenir sur ce que vous avez vu hier
dans cette tous ces gens qui venaient
des cinq continents et qui ailleurs
s'exprimera en anglais est bien là il
s'exprimait en français
et c'était un spectacle vraiment
extraordinaire je vois que la
francophonie c'est ça ce sont des gens
qui viennent de partout et qui
communient dans cet amour de la langue
française en pratiquant bien entendu
cette langue française voilà alors
maintenant nous allons procéder aux
corriger on va commencer d'abord par
lequel roger de la première partie qui
est elle consacrée aux juniors réservée
aux juniors alors à ma gauche
sacha distel qui a été très courageux
qui a fait ses dictées vous avez pas
vous avez fait combien de fautes
je crois que je suis au delà de la
douzaine ces savons enfin j'ai pour cent
pour un junior c'est bien ça et puis
anna prucnal anna prucnal go je vous
demande pas combien de fois comme il
faut que vous avez fait parce que
d'abord le français n'est pas vraiment
votre langue c'est c'est le jeune
polonais tous les pièges des faits
mineurs ouais tous les pièges mais les
pièges féminin sur les haies du chômage
je connaissais pas non plus mais c'est
vrai que les polonais connaissent pas
tous les fromages et les français non
plus combien faute je vais dans une seul
fromage déjà fait un don vous êtes
polonaise ou française je suis polonaise
est française depuis deux jours je suis
un nouveau polonaise
on m'a rendu ma nationalité voilà ça
c'est formidable en fait vous applaudir
et puis nous allons procéder aux corrigé
de la dictée avec le jury que je vous
présente à côté de emmanuel le roy
ladurie qu en train de ramasser ses
papiers ses antisèches il y à micheline
ce moment qui est linguiste marie-hélène
tournadre et qui est linguiste également
jean marie ego correcteurs jean pierre
colignon correcteurs et bernard legs
correcteurs également voilà alors
maintenant et bien
vous interviendrez évidemment sur les
mots tout était différent vous verrez
que grâce à ibm nous avons des
statistiques sur les fautes qui ont été
commises
cet après midi par les par les
candidates
alors on commence et je vous rappelle
que la littérature à l'estomac c'est un
titre célèbre de julien gracq la
littérature à l'estomac
entre mon gîte et la bibliothèque
nationale je suis souvent saisis d'une
fringale irrépressible alors saisi c'est
une femme qui parle c'est non pas un
homme c'est une femme qui parle et on en
avait la preuve
un peu plus loin à la fin de la dictée
junior lorsqu'on parlait lorsque son
père l'a rangé parmi les fanatiques de
la fourchette les ogresses et les
sybarites mais nous reviendrons
là dessus tout à l'heure et gîtes gide
ça prend un accent circonflexe
bien entendu on a body à ce qu'on aurait
on a beau dire les nourritures
intellectuelles ne saurait remplacer le
boire et le manger
il n'y avait aucune difficulté dans
cette phrase
donc on peut passer à la suivante quand
le corps crie famine et que les
leitmotivs de la fin surgissent
continûment lors normalement on devrait
prononcer les lettres motif enfin là
c'était encore égaré un peu plus les
concurrents donc j'ai préféré dire les
leitmotivs le
est-ce que
michine seulement pouvez nous expliquer
le pluriel bizarre de leitmotiv vient
d'un mot allemand dont le pluriel et
doit être motivé iv mais ce pluriel n'a
pas suffi en français il faut le croire
puisque la franchise est et on autorise
également light motifs vs à la fin donc
deux plurielle était autorisée pour
light motif alors on peut nous redonner
la statistique
jean cazenave c'était dont 46% des
concurrents aux commis la faute et 32%
commis la faute sur continûment c'est à
dire qu'il fallait mettre un accent
circonflexe
je signale que la faute de sens du début
le féminin a été commis c'est la seule
qui a été le plus souvent commises a été
commise par 61% des candidats mais ce
qui n'est pas quand même énorme nous
continuons ce n'est voilà saisi 1 61%
quand mon père morange et voilà nous
continuerons ce n'est la lecture ni de
racines ni de la fontaine ni de
chateaubriand qui peut apaiser une poche
stomacale rendu exigu par le jeune et
l'abstinence ce qu'on peut demander à
jean pierre colignon de nous expliquer
d'abord châteaubriant tiens comme chacun
a pu le constater il y avait là plein de
jeux de mots sur leurs racines
lafontaine et châteaubriant puisqu'on
rencontre à la fois la littérature et la
gastronomie
chateaubriand est un nom commun qui
vient du nom de françois rené de
chateaubriand puisque le cuisinier de ce
dernier qui s'appelait montmirail avait
créé à londres ce plat qui est une sorte
de gros bifteck si on veut il s'agissait
donc pas d'alphonse de châteaubriant
bien connu pour avoir écrit la grande
brière les racines aux soucis on est
vraiment pressé par la diversité aux
manches des racines mais faute de
beaujolais par exemple on se rabat sur
le de la fontaine marie hélène tour
nable pourriez vous expliquer là c'est
le exigu le tréma et bien le tréma se
met sur le e dans exigu bien que on
commence à tolérer pour certains
adjectifs le tréma sur le but mais on le
conserve encore sur le e dans exécute
féminin et un accent circonflexe sur
jeunes oui alors il ya un accent
circonflexe sur jeunes alors que dans
agen et dans le verbe déjeuner qui est
de la même famille il n'ya pas d'accent
circonflexe ne l'expliquent pas vraiment
merci hélène hayden alors jeune 16%
seulement oui c'est un gros piège au
comme il a commis la faute
quel martyrs que de devoir agen lire des
récits de pique nique extra de l'ip est
sublime et d'agapes excellemment ta rose
et agen c'est bernard legs qui nous
explique qu'on n'y a pas évidemment il
n'ya pas d'accent circonflexe la
prononciation d'ailleurs l'interdirait
mais avec jeune et il y en a un on l'a
vu et tout à fait logiquement déjeuner
qui veut dire sortir du jeune lui n'en a
pas le récit de pique nique extra
jean-marie égaux il ya deux éléments
d'ailleurs dans ce moule le pic est un
élément verbale qui vient du verbe piqué
c'est à dire donner un coup de dents et
il est forcément un variable comme
élément verbal et puis il y à nick qui
est un nom commun variable qui signifie
chose de peu de valeur donc le pluriel
annick alors les lip et sublime des lip
et ben ce sont des monts des réunions de
gastronomique très fraternel et puis
aussi d'ailleurs les agapes aussi dont
je crois que les l'ipc plus tôt je crois
qu'on hausse et lorsqu'on mange sans
payer je crois et les agapes ce sont des
réunions gastronomique à ces amicales
excellemment arrosé avec ios alors
est-ce que vous avez commis des fautes
la sacha distel
oui oui j'ai commis plein de fautes déjà
je n'ai pas mis l'accent circonflexe sur
continûment sur le but de continuer mon
leitmotiv j'avais mis un s et
en mes voisins j'ai triché ce qu'il faut
pas tricher dans ces trucs là m'ont
persuadé qu'il fallait pas death les ai
écoutés je les bars et ouais et
stomacale somme à calabasas et le côté
anglais de liste j'ai mis 1 h
ça vous êtes son influence anglaise bien
entendu les festins littéraires font
saliver et en dv les futurs agrégés sans
le sou c'est un mot un peu rare
michel sommer d'evry en dv est assez
rare c'est un monde dont l'accent
circonflexe s'explique par l'ancien
français dsv avec un ace qui s'est
transformé en accent circonflexe et qui
signifiait être fou faire en des wc
faire enrager rendre fou je me rappelle
les goûters de mon enfance quand mon
père me ranger parmi les fanatiques de
la fourchette les ogresses et les
sybarites alors allez-y habits chine
seulement expliqué donc le piège à les
sybarites bas le piège c'était le piège
des ogresses ici fanatiques peut être un
nom masculin ou féminin aux graisses et
de toute façon toujours féminin et si
barry peut être nom masculin ou féminin
donc votre piège résidait dans aux
graisses qui se défendent est tout à
fait avec les deux autres mots c'est ça
donc on peut évidemment le père ne peut
pas ne peut pas comparer sa fille anne
au bahreïn au grès et le piège c'était
se trouvait au milieu c'était je veux
dire un peu diabolique c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on m'a traité de criminel
puis le temps des vaches maigres est
arrivé est bien là il n'y a pas de il
n'y a pas de
de difficultés et nous arrivions à la
fin de l'épreuve des juniors et nous
allons procéder maintenant aux
récompenses pour ses juniors car j'ai
les résultats et vous allez voir qu'ils
sont très brillants
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin ça y est il faut bien
signalé une dernière que la dictée n'est
pas finie que tout à leur donnera le
corriger pour les seniors cette fois ci
je me souviens que je me rappelle je
m'en souviens je me rappelle qu'à chaque
fois il ya un piège bien spécifique l'an
dernier c'était d'étonnant la douzaine
ou anal selon la place assi fication ce
avait soulevé une vague de protestations
puis là les ogresses on sera à bord n'a
pas le même sens alors nous allons donc
l'a appelé les juniors les vainqueurs
junior en sachant qu'il ya un junior
français ingénieur francophone et un
junior de greny d'un pays étranger non
francophones champion de france junior
raphaël ulrich de lyon 19 ans une faute
et demi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
bravo on va appeler
champion junior des pays francophones
stéphane étiez canada de montréal 21
heures une faute et demi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour touré yokohama
installez-vous installé juste comme ici
champion des pays non francophones
junior toujours youssef la règle du
maroc 15 ans 15 ans 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
même chose sur cf prenez place ici on va
remettre les cadeaux
alors d'abord une médaille alors
peut-être qu'on va se faire aider un peu
des médailles on met aussi un qu'est ce
qu'on met bernard voilà le français pour
notre candidat france est candidate
tenez vous allez m'aider je suis vous
remettre une belle médaille vous
demander de vous baisser parce que à
vous avec un voyage à washington a bien
bien l'effet bienvenue chez les poils de
pierre l'art de faire la dictée mais oui
tout à fait combien cela ou moins 4,4
beauté un champion entêté sybarites les
axes ans agen a complètement perdu
voilà je vais demander à corinne lagarde
vous n'avez donc fait que que tel
pardon faute c'est ça une faute oui
comme une faute technique
j'ai fait une faute et demi la faute de
censure c'est zilog les ogresses moment
absolument pas frappé par cette question
et puis le mot en dv que je ne
connaissais pas du tout qui est un joli
mot un enragé voilà c'est un on apprend
des mots aussi et vous et bien ma faute
entière c'était une faute bête
c'était sur le genre d'agapes et puis la
même demi faute qu'elle a fait en dv
mais ça parait t'il enfin
quand des seniors professionnels du
québec me dit que sa mère dans la
campagne au québec utilisé ce mot là à
son intégration à son sujet vous savez
que vous étiez le favori de cette des
pays francophones et vous avez gagné 6,6
et vous donc vous avez été très brillant
aussi monsieur enfin un peu moins que ce
que je pensais parce que par la demi
finale j'ai fait deux fautes et là je
crois que j'ai un score qui est un peu
plus lourd mais fait très long
d'énumérer mais faute mais très peu très
peu à peu ses quatre fautes a saisi bon
évidemment mais chateaubriand a mis un
accent circonflexe sur le chateaubriand
sur une demi faute
et puis il ya les agapes ex éléments
arrosée qui sont féminins et non pas
masculin et puis les lip et vous avez
oublié 1 1 p c'est tout voilà c'est peu
c'est peu de chose alors pendant que
michel tu récompense tout le monde
détails graphiques raphaël ulrich à
gagner un voyage d'une semaine pour deux
personnes à destination rossington
offert par air france
avec hébergement dans un hôtel hilton
est il grand larousse en cinq volumes et
puis vous stéphane étiez vous avez gagné
vous avez gagné 1 une machine à écrire
ibm et le grand robert en 9 volumes plus
un stylo montblanc et puis monsieur
monsieur youssef marc est que vous avez
gagné à une machine à écrire ibm même
chose grand air en 9 volumes et un stylo
montblanc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sens ce sont les champions du monde
est il faut bien le dire à bernard les
champions du monde alors vous
représentiez ce qu'on appelle la filière
lire vous allez vous aviez été
sélectionné par l'irs on va maintenant
d'un a appelé le champion junior de la
filière scolaire qui avait été organisé
par le crédit agricole
oui alors c'est une jeune fille qui a
gagné elle s'appelle corinne lagarde l
aide qu à montferrand elle a 15 ans et
elle n'a commis que quatre fautes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
corinne lagarde est élève au lycée
fénelon de clermont ferrand voilà
mettez-vous là alors vous êtes donc la
meilleure de la filière scolaire et vous
n'avait commis que quatre fautes vous
avez gagné alors vous un voyage aussi
d'une semaine pour deux personnes à
destination de washington offert par air
france a hébergé dans un hôtel hilton et
le grand larousse en cinq volumes
vous êtes contente de votre performance
je voulais trouver dur l'a dit est
difficile c'est quand même pas mal quand
même
quatre fautes vous savez vos fautes oui
en effet saisi oui ça peut toujours les
mêmes
et puis à gap probablement voilà non pas
à gap un gars vous connaissiez un voilà
eh bien je crois qu'on peut tous les
applaudir parce qu'ils sont formidables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
bravo on va laisser redescendre bernard
tout doucement voile avec nouveau
certificat
ah oui ils n'avaient pas leurs
certificats quelle honte
puis un autre voilà voilà michel donc on
va les faire redescendre berlin parce
qu'il va continuer à le corriger de la
dictée vous rester avec moi moi c'est
avec moi parce que tout est là là vous
êtes venus ce qui est gentil parce que
tout l'aria champs elysées avec patrick
bruel c'est ça oui entre autres via dira
junior j'exagère avec la junior où il y
avait quelques seniors à quelques
seniors sur jalle avec lelouch lac
arcady avec lavilliers avec une autre
junior vanessa ah ouais avec une vraie
junior l'a donc nous reprenons le cours
de la dictée cette fois c'est le
corriger pour les seniors bernard assez
bien ça alors avant de passer aux
corrigé de la partie senior de la dictée
je voudrais vous donner les résultats du
concours de journalistes le
pour les français c'est anne branche
ficc de phosphore qui l'a emporté devant
sylvie overnoy de cosmopolitan et
christine courcol de la fp on peut les
applaudir
pour les pour les journalistes pour les
journalistes non francophones c'est
jacques altman de playboy qui a gagné et
et david lowe des deux us today et sacha
distel me dis que jacques altman de
playboy sida ass et david le dès qu'il
tombe offrait à lui ma femme et sa femme
censeurs ssab alors tu dois être
meilleur en orthographe lui doit être
meilleur et enfin pour les francophones
c'est alice silos et abraham jadwiga du
figaro tv et qui ont été les meilleurs
et maintenant nous reprenons le corrigé
de la dictée seigneur aujourd'hui je
suis parfois si obsédé par la fin que
penché sur les trésors de la
bibliothèque nationale
je les confonds avec ceux de la
gastronomie là aucune sauf que si vous
avez hormis obsédé épanché au masculin
le jury n'a compté qu'une faute une
seule faute pour les trois adjectifs
manuscrits médiévaux vais compter trois
fautes
ah bin là vous allez changer d'avis ah
bah vous est terrible voyez bien moi
j'étais beaucoup plus
moi j'étais beaucoup plus coulante le
jus rien moi je moi je racontais qu'une
faute
vous êtes diabolique et on traite de
criminel alors c'est vous les criminels
donc ils ont compté trois fautes
bah tant pis pour vous manuscrits
médiévaux et fricandeau palimpseste
minoens et court bouillon in folio est
seul il s est ce que me gilles seulement
vous pouvez nous parler des palimpsestes
minoens mais bien sûr c'est une chose
très connu les plans c'est ce sont des
parchemins manuscrits dont on a effacé
la première écriture pour écrire un
nouveau texte
voilà et minoens est un adjectif
qualifiant ce qui concerne le roi minos
qui était un souverain légendaire de la
crête ce terme domino c'est peut être un
titre porté par différents roi de crète
et l'adjectif minoens minoenne
s'applique donc à tout ce qui touche
cette période archaïque de l'histoire
gréco crétoise
jean-marie ego là le pluriel de
court-bouillon de infolio là c'était des
petits pièges alors court bouillon c'est
un nom composé est formé d'un adjectif
cours et puis de bouillon hannon et la
corde ont fait la corde des deux
éléments ce qui est conforme à la règle
généralement observée dans ce cas comme
les petites nièces les belles mères pour
infolio le nom d' in folio est
invariable aussi bien d'ailleurs comme
nombre que comme adjectif et le sol il s
je me réserve le plaisir de vous
l'expliquer ce mot c'est un beau
absolument délicieux la langue française
jeudi délicieux parce que il désigne la
partie du poulet qu'on appelle aussi le
croupion enfin qui est juste en dessous
de ce que vous imaginez et bien souvent
les gens un peu délicat disait non non
on peut pas manger ça alors les
restaurateurs qui eux savaient que
c'était du parti délicieuse du poulet
disait que seuls les imbéciles n'en
voulait pas elle est que les sauts la
rejeter 12 l expression le sot l'y
laisse le saut n'en veut pas le sol il s
et cela désigne donc en gastronomie
cette partie agréable du poulet et
d'ailleurs vous trouverez le mot sol il
s sur la carte de très grands
restaurants et notamment du côté de la
bresse alors palimpseste minoens 16 %
seulement des gens ont commis la faute
quelques-uns ont mis évidemment d un
tréma sur le c'était c'est un peu le
piège que vous aviez tendu micheline
cement et groenland aussi les gens
avaient mis un trait d'union second plan
infolio 10% seulement est seul il est ça
c'est une grande surprise 15% seulement
aux commis la faute là je crois que
méritée de vous applaudir vous même
[Applaudissements]
ainsi que les culs de lampes historiés
et les cancoillotte très parfumée l'écu
de l'amp
bernard legs à l'étude lampe
alors là on a évidemment un nom composé
avec deux traits d'union mais de toute
façon ici on le décortique bien il y a
un nom et un complément de nom et alors
dq de la décrit comme des culs de sac
c'est à dire que le s est aux premiers
parce que le complément de nom en
français en principe sauf exception il y
en a ne prend pas la marque du pluriel
est un exemple des queues de cheval mais
et que deux chevaux sauvages plus de
lampes historiens historiens ça veut
dire que ce sont des culs de l'homme qui
présente des personnages et les
cancoillotte alors j'aurais pu dire
peut-être mieux les cancoillotte car
c'est un fromage de franche comté à pâte
molle qui est assez célèbre en france
évidemment les gens fidèles qui venaient
des pays africains étaient était un peu
désavantagé par rapport aux notamment
aux gens de franche-comté ça va de soi
donc j'aurais pu dire mieux les
cancoillotte très parfumé et là il y
avait un autre piège c'est que les camps
la conque c'est la cancoillotte c'est un
mot féminin mais enfin vous avez fait
encore très fort là car vous n'avez vous
n'avez été seulement que 21% à commettre
cette erreur ce qui est vraiment très
peu sacha distel habig quand les
cancoillotte oui je savais ce que
c'était
connaissez vous en aviez manger oui oui
mais c'est bon mais par contre je suis
fait piéger sur les solidays s'alarmer
voyages m'ont porté encore très loin
j'ai rêvé si tant est qu'on puisse rêver
pour une chose pareille que ça
s'écrivait à l'espagnol des résaux ali
est le accent grave
est ce là le jury dans sa sévérité de
vous compter cinq faux témoignage au
moins ça alors j'en suis persuadé c'est
effrayant
vous connaissiez les qu'employé vraiment
vrai fromage de ces morts incroyable les
incunables et les pets de nonne
les incunables et les pets de nonne qui
les pets de nonne
c'est jean pierre colignon le
spécialiste du pedn solidement c'est
bien connu
pets de nonne correspond au pluriel de
cul-de-sac de kate biche et ses
terrasses et un nom composé de trois
éléments une préposition de nos convainc
donc encore au pluriel du premier
élément est le dernier élément reste
invariable sur incunables peu de choses
à dire et le pedn c'est une pâtisserie
rappelons le c'est une sorte de beignets
fait avec une patte je suis pas choquée
par ces tueries une pâte à choux elle
l'a donc c'était une sorte de beignets
seulement délicieux et vous connaissiez
le pedn à vous est il vrai française ya
des françaises qui connaît le monde
parce que vous êtes gourmandes les
petits livres et les petits beurres
marie-hélène tour nable petit beurre oui
petit beurre est un nom composé dont le
premier élément s'accordent c'est petit
c'est un adjectif est le deuxième
élément d'heure on peut considérer que
c'est la matière c'est comme une
abréviation de petits gâteaux au beurre
donc petit au fur yale et beurre au
singulier écrire elle un jour
l'autobiographie alors d'un pedn oui
pardon 9,6 pour cent ou alors vraiment
c'est rien du tout tout le monde connaît
les pets de nonne et petit beurre 13,2
pour cent
là les concurrents sont vraiment des
cracks et un seulement sur 10 a commis
la faute ce qui est vraiment très peu
écrire est un jour
l'autobiographie kid utilement coûter il
est admirable à ce petit stylo qui vient
souligner les fautes et je dois dire que
sous la direction de jean cazenave ce
sont des techniciens d'antenne 2 qui ont
inventé ce procédé est dans les jours
il y a quelques jours je voudrais que
pouvait les applaudir parce que je suis
persuadé que les téléspectateurs
bénéfices sont évidemment voix sam
beaucoup mieux que vous qui êtes ici
mais je suis persuadé que ce petit stylo
qui se balade dans les airs doit
beaucoup leur plaire je reviens au texte
dutil m'en coûter retracera la route
qu'on m'avait assuré être la plus facile
bernard l'aigle dutil m'en coûter accent
circonflexe
oui ben parce que c'est l'imparfait du
subjonctif tout simplement avec la une
valeur concessive c'est bien ça on dit
qu'on ccifj absolument on sait c est qu
on m'avait assuré être la plus facile
jean-marie ego assuré assuré est
invariable parce que le mot route n'est
pas le complément d'objet direct placé
devant le verbe comme on aurait par
exemple la route qu'on m'avait interdite
d'accord mais ici la réponse à la
question on m'avait assuré quoi c'est la
proposition entière placée derrière le
verbe que c'était là la route la plus
facile raconte rama jeunesse qui s'étend
au chercher tantôt fui
équipe u et mais qui eût aimé
s'empiffrer je vais demander à jean
pierre colignon de nous expliquer la la
corde chercher fui par équipe classique
c'est classique on cherche le complément
d'objet direct en l'occurrence il s'agit
du pronom personnel s on a cherché quoi
on a fui quoi la jeunesse c'est chercher
elle-même a fui elle-même et qui eût
aimé sampic s'empiffrer aussi des
accents circonflexes à confesse tout
simplement parce que c'est le
conditionnel passé deuxième forme alors
là oui le piège alors tomber
complètement à plat chercher 0,8 pour
0,8 pour cent seulement commis l'erreur
ce qui n'est rien et fuyait 6,8 pour
cent ont commis l'erreur ce qui est en
équipe vraiment très très bas qui s'est
défendu de souffrir qui s'est révolté et
dont les privations ont exaucé mon âme a
alors là il y avait un autre piège de
sens mais dans le piège de sens qui
s'est défendu là aussi
marie-hélène tournage et la cour
classique oui ce n'est qui a défendu à
elle même de souffrir donc s apostrophe
placé avant n'est pas complément d'objet
direct mais complètement indirects donc
on n'accorde pas défendu au féminin et
qui se révolte et qui s'est révolté est
oui et dont les privations ont exaucé
mon arbre et ça c'est aussi un piège de
sens
n'est ce pas mais ce lancement oui
exaucé a ici un sens particulier c'est à
dire élevées relevées on prend 1 h et 2
s il ne fallait bien sûr pas confondre
avec exo c'est un voeu alors le
raisonnement c'est comme la jeunesse
s'était révolté contre les privations
endurées ces dernières bien sûr ne vous
servent ne pouvait certes pas exaucés
c'est-à-dire combler satisfaire les
désirs de l'âme
c'était le sens opposé mais là c'était
un piège de sens bernard c'est un piège
de sang il y avait donc deux pièges de
sens et bien ce piège de ce sens n'a pas
aussi bien fonctionné que le premier
puisque seulement 15 % des gens ont
écrit exaucé e x a eu ses accents aigus
ce qui est vraiment très très peu là
aussi je vous méritez tous des
applaudissements et anna prucnal vous
avez fait cette faute là
ah bah oui mais oui mais c'est tout à
fait normal que vous ayez commis
beaucoup de fautes
quand votre pari dès maintenant nous
allons procéder et vous allez voir il ya
une grosse surprise
je vous en prie bien nous allons
procéder à la remise des prix pour les
seniors les seniors amateurs et on va
demander à sécher distel de venir avec
nous parce que là nous allons procéder
par étapes d'abord les seniors amateurs
et ensuite les seniors professionnels
avec toujours les trois catégories
seniors amateurs français seniors
amateurs francophones et s'ignorent
amateur des pays étrangers non
francophones avec un micro alors bernard
on va commencer par le theater france le
champion de france amateur c'est
monsieur laurent m'aurait bailly de
rennes 38 ans une faute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une faute une faute alors la gueule
tenez prenez place sur les livres le
champion de france amateur des pays
francophones
c'est un suisse s'appelle monsieur
jacques evelyne et l'a commis quatre
fautes et demi seulement a séduit
pardon c'est une dame pardon à ses
madame evelyne jacques non à celle
inverse et pacha qu'evelyne c'est madame
evelyne jacques on l'applaudît notre
place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et enfin champion amateur des pays non
francophones
louise mes amours d'algérie 42 ans six
fautes sans profession
[Applaudissements]
voilà
voilà ça c'est la catégorie donc des
seniors amateurs
alors venez prenez place et c'est sacha
distel qui va vous remettre le prix
alors vous vous monsieur laurent barret
baïse à gagner un voyage d'une semaine
pour deux personnes pour abidjan offert
par la compagnie thé a avec hébergement
dans un hôtel hilton et le grand
larousse en cinq volumes deuxième
médaille madame evelyn evelyn jacques et
non pas monsieur jacques evelyne vous
avez gagné vous une machine écrit ibm le
grand robert nos volumes et un stylo
montblanc et enfin louise messaoud gagne
même chose une machine et créer bm dont
robert nos volumes et le stylo montblanc
voila voila et un certificat
et monsieur laurent bailly vous n'avez
commis qu'une faute
laquelle j'aimais déjà mis 1
un ace à infolio rémi reiss est une
folie au cv lafreux non c'est pas vrai
vous êtes tellement fort que vous auriez
pu l'éviter je ne sais pas non je
regrette pas trop là je ne savais
vraiment pas mais vous n'êtes pas tomber
dans le piège de sens de la dame
non non j'ai repéré l'ogresse tout de
suite donc vous l'avais repéré vous ai
dit là il ya plus d'un piège il faut que
je fasse attention
oui oui bien sûr vous êtes quand même
très fort et quel est votre profession
un mathématicien voilà
[Musique]
vous savez je recevais je recevais hier
apostrophe un très grand mathématicien
qui a obtenu la médaille fils s'appelle
monsieur alain connes et je me demande
d'ailleurs si lui aussi ne doit pas être
très fort en orthographe et je me
reproche de ne pas l'avoir invité à
venir faire cette dictée aujourd'hui
mais j'espère passer monsieur alain
connes m'écoute je l'invite pour l'année
prochaine devrait voir je suis sûr qu'il
doit très très fort aussi ans
alors madame evelyne jacques quatre
fautes et demi on va vous dire parce que
nous avons votre tapis poche stomacale
vous avez mis 1 h comme sacha distel la
même faute que sacha distel celle
influence de l'anglais et puis vous avez
fait une faute à aller cancoillotte ben
oui c'est ça la vous étiez un peu et en
dv vous avez oublié l'accent circonflexe
madame louise mes amours seulement 6
fautes c'est trop mais non c'est pas
beaucoup les leitmotivs les leitmotivs
vous êtes tombés dans le piège de sens
saisi les pique-niques vous n'avez pas
mis un et agapes excellemment tard osez
vous a coûté deux fautes
enfin bravo bravo bravo on vous
applaudit bravo à tous et des jeux
propose de rester
là les places là restez avec nous nous
allons maintenant passer aux
professionnels seniors professionnels
seniors professionnels français nous
allons appeler anna prucnal et c'est là
que pour venir redonner les prix
la grande surprise anna prucnal en effet
le champion de france professionnel vous
l'applaudir après s'appelle monsieur
jacques fils est il gay de strasbourg il
a 43 ans 0 foot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
on déplace
mon projet je vous demande tout de suite
votre profession professeur de lettres
classiques professeur de lettres
classiques ça professionnels
ah oui là champion de france
professionnel des pays francophones
madame christiane ray de l'île maurice
deux fautes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on a et on a entendu un cri de joie
quand même entendu son nom et les
poussins creech louise âgée c'est
l'explosion de joie
c'est un jour vraiment eu vraiment être
heureux la scène et enfin champion de
dpi champion professionnel des pays non
francophones crida fils guy bonne
d'irlande quatre fautes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à nous sommes vraiment très heureux
d'accueillir l'irlande est mon plaisir
ressenti une émotion
sacha distel va vous remettre vos
récompenses comme aux jeux olympiques à
et anna prucnal bravo avec les médailles
alors disons que jacques fils est vous
avez gagné vous un voyage d'une semaine
pour deux personnes à destination
d'abidjan offert par la compagnie thé
avec hébergement évidemment l'hôtel
hilton et ben et et le grand larousse en
cinq volumes et je me demande si ça va
vous apprendre quelque chose de grand
larousse en cinq volumes d'abord vous
l'avez déjà un
vous n'avez pas au balo réputés comme
bon vous savez peut-être pas tous là et
puis le madame christiane ray une
machine à écrire ibm le grand robert
neuf volumes et le stylo montblanc mais
ça va aussi vous allez être ça doit pas
besoin de grand chose et quand robert
nos volumes si celui-ci est donc crida
fils guy bonne là aussi machine à écrire
le robert et le stylo et jeux wii et
puis non je veux dire quand même ce
héros faute c'est quand même
extraordinaire
j'allais vivre cette professionnelle de
sûr mais ce que vous êtes entraîné quand
même juste avant oui vous dis je suis un
rescapé des demi finales je vais pas
tellement brillé et je me suis mis au
travail parce que j'étais soutenu par
tous les élèves et beaucoup d'autres
jours mais c'est une belle aventure
ah oui est ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous avez préparé sérieusement et madame
vous avez fait que que deux fautes
abo oui elbow de fautes leitmotiv que
j'ai pas remis au père jan est petit
beurre je n'ai pas remis à madame
critique est bonne
donc 4 fautes seulement oui c'est
étonnant je dois faire très mal calculé
ça pouf d'être mauvaise en mathématiques
est excellente en français je travaille
dans une banque où travaille dans une
banque
mais pourquoi êtes vous rangé parmi les
professionnels
je fais de la traduction a fait la
traduction du très bien et bien bravo à
tous
voilà
[Applaudissements]
ah oui oui mais attendez à notre club à
vous remettre vos certificats quand même
unité
ils peuvent monter tous ensemble à quand
les appelle le meilleur set up when
attention des prix spécial as et des
prix spéciaux vous pouvez monter c'est
bientôt la fin de l'émission de guyane
c'est nicole mounier qui l'a emporté
avec deux fautes et demi seulement
qu'ils gagnent carte du monde ou connu
ans et 168e faire par ign à la jeune
nicole montée je peux me dire ici le
meilleur finalistes d'europe
francophones
c'est maurice daubié du luxembourg 3
fautes et demi bravo mais n'est le
meilleur finalistes non francophones
d'europe paire d'as garde du danemark
cette faute et demi
[Musique]
deuxièmes meilleurs finalistes du
maghreb et du moyen-orient le premier
champion junior des pays non
francophones
c'est bnl bout phoque d'algérie cinq
fautes
meilleurs finalistes des pays non
francophones d'asie et d'extrême orient
et d'océanie anne a vu les clients
l'australie 78 78
on l'a la formule 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
meilleurs finalistes du continent
américain non francophones françoise
reiki bouche usa 56 ans cette faute
[Musique]
et enfin meilleurs finalistes des pays
francophones d'afrique noire et de
l'océan indien
7 c'est marina peu bahamas fou du zaïre
17 ans deux fautes seulement
[Musique]
alors quand on parlait compte de
l'internationalisation sas et formulant
la tous les âges et tous les pays on va
peut-être demander aux juniors
d'ailleurs de remonter de revenir avec
nous pour que nous soyons tous ceux là
voilà je vais en profiter puisque vous
venez prénois vous êtes bien de réparer
un surprises aussi
elle avait chef bien rester une grande
une grande émotion mais maintenant c'est
la fin de l'émission je vais appeler
tous ceux qui ont concouru à la réussite
de cette manifestation
c'est à dire j'appelle philippe jaffré
du crédit agricole rejet goze alliances
françaises rhône et la peau du thé à
aller vous pouvez monter alésia l'isi
gérard orizet d'air france jean claude
noël dulic tonnes bruno favier dit bm
vous êtes attendus alesi un peu de un
peu de vigueur un peu d'énergie
bernard donnet du mont-blanc emmanuel le
roy ladurie team usa si bien accueilli
messieurs compte de france télécom
jacqueline leboube de britannique anne
marie marie france rose de chez laffont
bertil et celle de la rousse
je remercie d'ailleurs tous les éditeurs
pouvait applaudir les éditeurs qui ont
été formés à pizol donné beaucoup de
choses dominique henriot d'universalisme
chantal je sais qu de nathan denis
allemand fasse lui robert clarisse
dollfus watier et anne-marie boel de
moët et chandon
voilà l'été et je vois là je voudrais
remercier
alors outre monsieur leroy ladurie tout
le personnel de la bibliothèque
nationale qui a vraiment beaucoup
travaillé pour l'accueil de ces
championnats d'orthographe vraiment
merci à tous et je signale
qu'actuellement on a nous avons tous
ensemble aller tous ces finalistes et
nous mêmes nous avons organisé une nous
avons visité la l'exposition les trésors
d'apn venez voir et vous verrez
notamment le manuscrit de don giovanni
de mozart le manuscrit de proust à la
recherche du temps perdu
la première est 17ème édition du
testament de françois villon c'est une
exposition tout à fait extraordinaire et
puis enfin
ben voila j'ai remercié je crois tout le
monde veut venir et je vous dit à
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et préparez vous bien pendant toute
cette année rendez-vous donc l'année
prochaine quand le championnat
d'orthographe de langue française les
championnats du monde en sauvegarde de
langue française
[Musique]